this morning on a special edition of the
dish we drop by a six-course dinner
between the flavors of both South Korea
and the American Southwest but food was
only part of the attraction Jamie wax is
here with the ingredients for a very
special meal good morning Rina for chef
Jaejoong the meal is a lifetime in the
making she recently participated in a
month-long dining experiment that
converted a New York City school
cafeteria into a fine dining room it's
called story course and its creators
felt that chef J's life had all the
ingredients for a new type of dining
experience
chef Jaejoong has worked in some of
America's greatest restaurants from
August in New Orleans to la Bernadin in
New York have you guys done this man but
on this night she's preparing the meal
of her life in a school cafeteria what
is it about chefs that makes their
stories great every chef seems to have a
great story I think it's more about
childhood things that you grew up with
you will never forget about her story
dubbed how do you hug a tiger tells of
Chef Jay's journey against her mother's
wishes from South Korea to America to
become a chef you call your mom a tiger
mom yeah can you tell me what that means
she's a very strong intense person
Korean moms are pretty tiger mom but
she's a super tiger my mom is crazy very
intense person but she was my
inspiration each chapter is revealed
through diners reading from a script
which is followed by a course I went to
sleep watching her through my window
stirring that chilli sauce on the
rooftop under the stars chapter one the
chili sauce Jay would watch her mother
make morning and night on the rooftop of
their apartment so for course one I give
you the most Korean astiz that this
Korean ever Korean chill jump on is
seven essential Korean ingredients
wrapped in a crib and topped with her
tape on the rooftop sauce you can't call
this a meal what you've put together
right yeah it's hard it's like we call
it a dinner is it is it a theater
experience that a story is at a show
it's story course was conceived after
Adam Cain
enter who's currently on Broadway in the
bands visit
[Music]
and Bryan Bourdain ik who's dinner lab
experiment put diners in direct contact
with up-and-coming chefs were introduced
by a mutual friend
we were actually fortunate enough to
host that Passover Seder that was really
interactive and it was through this
telling the story of Exodus this
migration story and looking at ways to
bring it to life we're living in New
York City it's a city that is so filled
with amazing immigrant chefs from all
over the world and they're often cooking
somebody else's vision someone else's
story so we were thinking about how can
we excavate those stories and allow for
like a beautiful delicious six-course
meal for their first story they settled
on chef Jay who first met Bourdain ik
when they were both living in New
Orleans I've known Jay for for over five
years and I kid you not
it wasn't until Adam started
interviewing her and talking to her that
I actually felt like I got to like know
her on such a different level yeah I
mean we just spent hours and hours like
on my couch just really digging into her
story and on a deep level she really
went to some vulnerable places chapter
three yearning beyond explains how Jays
mother wanted more for her daughter than
life in the kitchen they didn't want me
to be a chef like my mom in Korea chefs
aren't seen like doctors lawyers etc
that's what they wanted for me to get
back to how we were before the war to
make them proud but why can't I pursue
my dreams I would say chapter 4 the slap
reenacts the dramatic moment when Jay
tells her mom she'd been accepted to the
Culinary Institute of America this part
of the story is burned into my brain
she slept and was slapped in the face
so in course for diners are asked to
slap a cracker over an egg with a spoon
how important is it no matter how much
creativity you put into it who the
collaborators are that the food is
really excellent it's we were really
trying to make sure that the
performative elements and the and the
culinary elements worked in service of
each other so you're going from Michelin
star and the Tony Award
yet after a musical number chef J
appears to explain that while she never
got a hug from her mom before leaving
for America her mom did send $20,000 Jay
desperately needed to stay in school and
fulfill her dream what do you think your
mother would think of this evening that
was doesn't know the whole thing under
person she doesn't know all the conflict
part and she wouldn't be so happy but
thank God it's in English over the
course of eight meals approximately 40
diners at night have been moved by chef
J's story that's my own rooftop table
even after forking over a hundred and
seventy-five dollars for a seat at the
table proving there is a hunger for this
type of dinner theater why do you think
audiences now are seeking out deeper
more interactive experiences in
everything that they do it's a good
question I mean obviously our world is
becoming more and more technological we
were glued to our phones where we're
becoming isolated in so many ways so an
experience around food that brings
people together I think this is
essential today Cantor and Board Anik
are currently working on their next
Story course with Chef Bazar MCD
chronicling his parents dramatic escape
from the Shahs regime in Iran I love
this concept Jamie I want to know did
she ever get that hot well she's got a
hug from me that night after pork belly
but yes actually last November she was
leaving Korea to come back to America
and her mother was in tears and she just
went for it and gave the hug and got the
hug that she's been searching for to
hear that this kid gives new meaning to
the phrase dinner theater Jamie